okay let's not delay any further i know
people are anxiously waiting for this
week's hatred mail if you've never heard
hatred mail before
this is hatred mail
if ein rand and ronald reagan had a baby
and suckled that child off the teat of
liberty
its cries would sound a little something
like
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
so our audience actually bearing the
brunt of a lot of
the ire of hatreds recently yet another
hatred mail focusing not just on
attacking me but on attacking our entire
audience take a listen to this
not only is pacman a loser closet gay
and a [ __ ]
all of his fans are exactly the same you
stupid pacman sucking morons you need to
get off air like
fellow jew norman goldman he feels like
a beta loser basically
now is exact reason we will never know
sad you know i
hope that um the lgbt
members of our audience are not quote in
the closet
i can understand why if you are watching
religious shows all the time
like pat robertson or who knows any of
these other wacky shows brian fisher
i could understand uh why you would end
up
maybe hiding your genuine uh
sexual orientation but i hope that to
the extent that the hatred is being
serious
that we have quote closet gays in our
audience
i hope that if i've achieved one thing
with the david pakman show
it's making it so that lgbt members of
our audience
feel empowered and comfortable uh saying
who it is that they are
and living their lives as such so i
reject the assertion
of this hatred um at its face but what i
will remind you
is that if you want to fight back
against the hatred if you want to send a
double middle finger to the hatreds
use the coupon code hatred 40 when you
sign up
at www dot join pacman.com
you save 40 percent and hundreds of
thousands of patriots cry
every single time that that coupon code
is used